the fallout from Bob Woodward's book
about the Trump White House continues
and today I want to focus in on comments
from Gary Cohn who's a former economic
adviser of Donald Trump's who says
according to Bob Woodward's book this is
pretty full on that Donald Trump has the
IQ of an inbred tanning bed which is
really a nice comedic touch because just
saying he has the IQ of a tanning bed is
sort of funny and it maybe is a
connection to Donald Trump's fake
tanning which he is so known for but
adding the touch about the inbred
tanning bed really puts it over the top
for me and this is now not merely
anecdotal that's really the story for me
the people who stopped working for
Donald Trump and don't have some
personal interest in not disparaging him
sometimes they're party to
non-disclosure agreements that they
choose to abide by although sometimes
they choose to ignore them or those who
are not hired to be Trump apologists so
Corey Lewandowski Trump's former
campaign manager sort of famously left
Trump's World Organization campaign
administration whatever and went on CNN
but he was hired as the Trump guy so he
wasn't going to go on and say bad things
those who just leave and say what's on
their minds seem to say really bad
things about Donald Trump including that
the reality is way worse than what the
public knows and that's exactly what
Gary Cohen who was part of the Goldman
Sachs wing of the Trump administration
is saying according to Bob Woodward's
new book Cohn was the director of the
National Economic Council for Trump for
a little while and he was reportedly
stunned by how ignorant Trump was
starting from day one
Trump has according to a cone and from
what we know a pretty fundamental
misunderstanding of basic economics and
even of how money works remember that
phone call he made to one of his
national security advisors Michael Flynn
to ask him about whether the dollar
going up
down was good for the United States and
Gary cones anecdotes about Trump's money
knowledge are truly amazing cone told
according to Bob Woodward cone told
Trump that the Fed was probably going to
be increasing interest rates during
Donald Trump's first term and Trump
allegedly said we should just go borrow
a lot of money hold the money and then
sell the money for more and we will make
money and Cohn explained to him no no if
we borrow money that increases the
deficit and you said you wanted to get
rid of the deficit to which Trump
responded just run the presses print
money according to Bob Woodward so the
trend is Trump is ignorant his first
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson called
him a [ __ ]
defense secretary Jim mattis according
to Bob Woodward told close associates
that Trump quote had the understanding
of a fifth or sixth grader former White
House deputy chief of staff Katie Walsh
reportedly said that working with Trump
was quote like trying to figure out what
a child wants I don't even know that I
agree because you can usually figure out
what the child wants it doesn't seem to
be clear what Trump wants and Scott
Pruett the EPA director said in not so
many words that Trump has effectively no
understanding whatsoever of both the
Constitution and the rule of law Pruitt
one of the most corrupt and vile members
of trumps administration even sees the
absurdity of what he's dealing with with
Donald Trump and now you have Gary cone
saying that Trump has the IQ of an
inbred tanning bed there are two kind of
parallel levels of debate or discussion
taking place right now on the right
within the right you're starting to see
some people engage in a debate with
trumpets about whether Trump truly is or
isn't qualified to be President that's
actually kind of a win like just the
fact that we're seeing some Republicans
say okay i Hillary's a disaster I hate
Hill
she's evil she should be locked up
whatever but Trump may not be qualified
to be President but I'm still a
Republican and I want a Republican to be
President the left is beyond that we're
now mostly exploring on the left whether
Trump is qualified to I don't know run a
car wash and I don't want to insult car
wash owners I think the answer is
clearly no Trump's not even qualified to
run a car wash and car wash owners
likely are more qualified than Trump to
be President they probably have some
basic understanding of how money works
Breaking Bad I guess would be one
example of that but the this is
alternate universes we're seeing this
fork this divergence where on the right
were desperate to see even just a few
introspective critical comments about
listen maybe this guy shouldn't be
president whereas on the Left we're
saying this is a crisis of monumental
proportions we are going to continue
scaling up our coverage of the 2018
midterm elections as we get closer and
closer now seven and a half weeks away
and what I want to talk to you about
today is that there is a major major a
growing problem for Republicans and for
Donald Trump and as a result of Donald
Trump's lack of popularity in the
Midwest okay the overall advantage for
Democrats in the upcoming midterms has
grown significantly over the last two
months and there are all sorts of
different voter models you can look at
that look at the Senate that look at the
House of Representatives based on
leaning and likely seats and different
likely voter models but the big picture
is that the numbers have dropped gone
significantly in the direction of
Democrats over the last two months the
voting group that is responsible for
that swing away from Republicans and
Trump endorsed Republicans and towards
Democrats are voters in the Midwest of
the United States of America they have
swung 13 percentage points since July
towards Democrats and it's not just one
poll there's this national NPR Marist
Poll which shows that
the 2018 midterm sort of outlook has
swung significantly toward Democrats
over the last two months if you look at
Marist state-by-state polls you will see
that the big changes are in the Midwest
and it is again away from Republicans
and towards Democrats now this could
actually be this it's almost like kind
of obvious but it doesn't happen that
often this could actually be people in
the Midwest realizing that Trump is
screwing them big-time and is screwing
them specifically more than he's
screwing most other people in the United
States of America Trump's abortive
tariffs which I've been talking about
for months are bad for mostly everyone
but they're especially bad for people in
the Midwest who work in farming and who
work in manufacturing to pick a couple
of industries wouldn't it be wonderful
if quite simply people reacted to
politicians passing policy that's bad
for them by saying I'm going to vote for
someone else the rich do it right the
rich see very clearly okay this is who's
going to give me a tax cut or this is
who's going to give my business a tax
reduction and that's who I'm going to
vote for and I'm gonna use the money
that I have surplus money because I've
been getting those tax cuts from
Republican presidents for a long time
and I am going to refund all it back in
to people who are going to pass laws
that are good for my checkbook but good
good for my pocketbook good for my bank
account whatever whatever metaphor or
analogy you want to use what if the
farming industry and the manufacturing
industry in the Midwest simply said this
guy screwing us we're going to vote for
someone else we're going to put aside
what might be differences on social
issues and we're going to vote for
somebody who is not actively part of the
problem that is screwing us day after
day after day now let's talk about what
needs to happen in the Midwest and in
other parts of the country in November
polls are nice but voting is what counts
and President Obama former President
Obama has been talking about this and so
have many others whatever the polls say
these Midwesterners and everybody else
must get out and vote and we are going
to start putting together possible sort
of result scenarios 538 has been doing
some really good work on this and there
are other websites that are doing really
really good mathematical work here and
all of that matters but every single
person that watches the show that
listens to the show needs to treat
whatever race you can participate in by
voting or by phone banking or by
volunteering or donating treat every
race as 50/50 make sure you were
registered to vote and actually do vote
but then if you have the means to donate
donate if you have the time to volunteer
or if you can make time and I think that
you should do that and when you look at
these different election previews like
the one on five thirty eight.com check
out some of those races they'll often be
ranked as safe Democrat and Republican
likely Democrat and Republican and
leaning Democrat and Republican those
leaning and likely are the ones where
get out the vote and phone banking and
all of that type of activism can
actually make a difference so please
please do it this is a massive you
should be engaged period because this
stuff matters and if you watch the show
you probably already are engaged to some
degree otherwise you'd be watching or
listening to something else but this is
an opportunity in terms of the
importance of these midterms that does
not come up all the time it has been a
long time since there have been midterms
of this degree of consequence if you
don't plan to vote okay
I'm speaking directly to you now please
email me and explain to me why you don't
plan to vote in November I can't think
of any good reasons not to vote in
November and if you don't plan to vote
other than you know there's some
logistical reason why you're not going
to be voting if you're gonna choose not
to vote please tell me I want to hear
from you and I also want to hear from
you on Twitter where you can find me at
des Pakman follow me there you can also
follow the show on twitter at david
pakman show we'll take a quick break we
have a fantastic program for you today
in this next story I'm going to give you
the headline as it was reported and then
I'll give you the deed
which surprisingly are not actually as
exciting as the headline suggests you've
probably heard that Donald Trump has
been accused of various forms of sexual
assault by all sorts of different people
all women I believe and this even
includes forcible rape of a minor girl
okay
one of the women who accused Trump is
summer servos who was a contestant
previously on The Apprentice which is
this reality show that Donald Trump
hosted years ago so the news as it's
being reported is Trump will have to
answer questions in a case involving
summer servos that's true
but now I'm going to give you all the
mitigating factors that make this much
less of a big deal than it might sound
like so first of all this is a
defamation lawsuit it's not a criminal
trial so yes it is a case but it's a
defamation lawsuit not a criminal trial
number two Donald Trump will answer the
questions technically but they are going
to be answered in writing by his
attorneys so this is going to make it
extraordinarily unlikely that anything
notable or controversial is going to
come from it number three even though it
still would be a crime to lie on the
written answers as I mentioned earlier
in the show perjury is both incredibly
difficult to prosecute and you can
indict a sitting president on criminal
charges you have to impeach them so even
if Trump lied in his written answers
about the defamation suit by some some
reserve OHS he's not going to get
impeached for lying on answers in a
defamation lawsuit from summer servos so
yeah Trump has been ordered to answer
questions but his lawyers are going to
provide answers that we know aren't
going to contain any significant amount
of substance it's interesting it's not
nothing but it would be endlessly more
interesting at this point simply to get
Donald Trump's tax returns rather than
answers in a summer servos defamation
lawsuit the one interesting legal thing
here that I do want to mention and that
that we actually have been talking about
for a while is that yes Donald Trump any
president the consensus the legal
consensus seems to be that
immune from criminal prosecution during
his presidency he may even be even be
immune from being forced to testify in
criminal trials during his presidency
that's less clear this is a civil case
which while it would lead to at worst
Donald Trump you know maybe having to
give some reserve us money the President
does not have immunity from such cases
and the president is also not immune to
civil penalties while presidents so some
reserve OHS could win the defamation
lawsuit and Trump could have to pay up
his position as president wouldn't
affect that I want to go back to one
other thing in both the civil and
criminal matters that Donald Trump is
dealing with so in this case it's a
civil matter defamation lawsuit from
from an accuser criminal like the Trump
Moeller Russia investigation Trump's
lawyers constantly are saying he's way
too busy to actually show up and testify
or to answer questions so he's going to
have to do it in writing with Muller
they want the questions in writing in
this case they wanted and got an
agreement that allows them to answer the
questions in writing Trump genuinely
doesn't seem too busy to show up to this
stuff he's golfing 25% of the time twice
a day I think it was 9:30 and 4:30 he
gets a propaganda file of positive news
coverage he watches cable news for hours
every single morning
he holds rallies all over the country
that are for a presidential race that
hasn't even really started yet he tweets
for hours every single night he's not
too busy
it's simply untrue and it would be great
if at some point a judge or an
investigator or someone said wait wait a
second you're clearly not too busy
you're gonna have to show up because
you're spending a quarter of your time
golfing but then of course the dreaded
perjury trap could happen I actually
fret I'm not gonna you know you all know
where I'm not gonna say where but it's
one of these trumpian enclaves of the
internet I read some crumb pused saying
it's good that he's going to answer
these questions in writing because
otherwise he could fall for a perjury
trap this is a defamation case that is
civil if there's going to be a place
where Donald Trump
you would think would just say I'm gonna
tell the truth because the truth is far
simpler here it would be in this
particular instance but alas you can't
really talk sense into them if you were
not following the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show you
missed great pictures from my trip
including one with former david pakman
show producer louis follow the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show and make sure to follow me as well
i'm on instagram at david pakman today's
program is made possible in part by
movement you guys have heard me talk
about those two college dropouts that
started their own watch company movement
em VMT
the company has grown like crazy they've
now sold almost two million watches in a
hundred and sixty countries i still
alternate my two
MV MT watches they start at just 95
bucks and movement continues to
revolutionize fashion on the belief that
style should not break the bank i don't
know if you've checked the site out
lately but they've doubled the number of
watch styles they continue to expand and
they've also introduced sunglasses and
fashion forward bracelets for her i had
a chance to do some very extensive
testing on the sunglasses during my road
trip in california a few months ago i
sat on them twice while driving a rental
car didn't break i still wear them my
favorite new style is the revolver
collection which you can check out at
MVM t.com slash Packman which will also
get you 15% off free shipping and free
returns cy movement keeps growing check
out their expanding collection go to MVM
t.com slash pakman join the movement
support our advertisers which also
supports us let's talk about what's
going on with Brett Kavanaugh the Senate
Judiciary Committee held hearings about
Donald Trump's Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh last week they're
scheduled to vote on
number xx and what has transpired in
these hearings is nothing short of
absolutely stunning now I could spend a
bunch of time talking about this amazing
exchange that took place between Senator
camel Harris and Kavanagh during which
Cavanaugh sort of played dumb and played
semantic games around whether or not he
had spoken to people in the justice
system about the robert muller trump
russia investigation but that was dealt
with last week by our guest hosts
adequately so i'm gonna move on from
that what i want to talk to you about
today is about straight-up perjury right
lying under oath during confirmation
hearings remember that Brett Kavanaugh
has had confirmation hearings before he
has had confirmation hearings in at
least in 2004 and 2006 for lower Court
judgeships and like last week he was
similarly under oath during these prior
confirmation hearings and we now have a
treasure trove of documents that have
been released relating to Brett
Kavanaugh and there is just too much
that directly contradicts things he said
during these prior confirmation hearings
over the years to say that they were
anything other than lies now of course a
lie is not necessarily perjury perjury
is very difficult to prosecute and prove
but we'll talk about that a little bit I
also want to make clear this the the
details not the specifics but the
details of each of the lies aren't so
important I'm going to give you the
overview of each of the lies because
really what I want to talk about is the
bigger picture so here's one example a
Republican aide to the Senate Judiciary
Committee named Manuel Miranda stole
thousands of documents belonging to the
DNC back in 2002 Cavanaugh denied having
received any of the stolen documents in
confirmation hearings in both 2004 and
2006 some of the documents that were
released show that Cavanaugh did indeed
receive documents from Manuel Miranda
light that's lie number one okay line
number two in 2006 Cavanaugh said that
he knew nothing about the war
less wiretapping under george w bush
carried out by the NSA emails provided
to the new york times in the last week
show that Cavanaugh was involved in at
minimum the initial discussions around
that NSA warrantless wiretapping program
and he specifically was asked by Justice
Department attorney John you remember
him we've talked about him before about
the Fourth Amendment implications of
this program that is line number two
line number three from Brett Kavanaugh
told under oath back in 2006 during that
confirmation hearing he said he wasn't
involved in any legal questions
surrounding the detention of enemy
combatants recently released records
show that there are at least three
recordings of Cavanaugh participating in
such discussions line number four in
2004 Brett Kavanaugh claimed not to have
worked on the selection of William prior
to the 11th Circuit Court this is a
controversial nomination because at the
time prior called roe v wade quote the
worst abomination of constitutional law
in our country turns out that Cavanaugh
was involved in selecting prior in
interviewing prior and then working on
getting his nomination through the
Senate
these are super clear Kavanagh said
quote I was not involved in handling his
nomination that's from a transcript and
we then have emails where Cavanaugh is
invited to emergency umbrella meetings
about the nomination and confirmation
process for lives lastly number five in
2006 this one's a little more nebulous
Kavanaugh downplayed his involvement in
the nomination of Charles Pickering he
said he wasn't primarily handling it
once again emails suggest he was way
more involved than he admitted so
question number one is Brett Kavanaugh
going to be charged with perjury for
these lies the answer is no perjury in
general is notoriously difficult to
prosecute perjury charges take up a ton
of time and research it's not enough
merely to prove that a witness said
something that was false you actually
have to prove that when they said the
falsehood
I knew that it was a falsehood that goes
to their state of mind and what was in
their heads so forget about the legal
consequences of the perjury here but now
this becomes part of the bigger picture
around Kavanagh which is that a huge
portion of the records about him are
being withheld that he has had now a
string of very concerning answers or
really non answers during the recent
confirmation hearings and he has a
history of playing sort of very fast and
loose with the truth and by the way I
know that this is like this ship has
sailed but he shouldn't even be there
right because Merrick garland should be
on the Supreme Court right now President
Obama's nominee who didn't even get
hearings and then of course it's
important not to forget that we may be
dealing with a president who achieved
the White House through criminal
collusion with a foreign power so
there's like the third layer and then
the second layer and then the primary
layer which are all of these lies that
Brett Cavanaugh has been caught telling
historically all of these are reasons
that Democrats and Republicans should
grow a spine and say if there was ever a
nominee that needed to be blocked it's
this one okay you know I said I was
going to consider whether or not John
Roberts was the right person for the job
but in the end it was really no reason
other than political disagreements to
not put him on the court or Republicans
with a you know Sonia Sotomayor or one
of President Obama selections put that
aside and say this is different
I've got a president who may have
achieved the White House illegally we
have a situation where it was wrong it
was wrong to block Merrick garland from
having hearings and the guy that Trump
has nominated we're not getting the
records he's lying under oath he's not
answering questions we have to say no
this time is there any chance that
they're actually going to do that
probably not probably not send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
and it is great to be back with you
today this is a next story is one of
those stories about the headline versus
the reality what I mean by that is we
often
come to you with a story where I will
tell you here's the headline of how it's
being reported and then here's the
reality or here's the sort of more
important angle Donald Trump and aides
are reportedly according to some
headlines on tape laughing and joking
about that horrible terrorist ambush
that took place in Nazaire in 2007 that
left four American servicemembers dead
now you might remember our coverage of
that incident it happened in October of
2017 nearly a year ago u.s. special
forces were attacked and four of them
ended up losing their lives there is a
recording that has been made by former
White House communications aide Omarosa
Manigault lines would lead you to
believe that Trump is straight-up
laughing and joking about the deaths of
those four u.s. military service members
now I'm gonna play it for you and if
you're like me you will quickly realize
that the news here is not Trump laughing
about the deaths of servicemembers but
it's something else
so let's take a listen to this clip we
want you less water for this
we have a lot of things happening on the
economic front
I think we had the military
you know and now for those years so what
happens is we've decimated every
so rough business thereof to want to
kill us
we've let the military do with that to
do and when you call tools of engagement
or anywhere you want to say it what we
let them do and in the Middle East has
very few left we really we've done our
job we've done more in seven months
because really at seven months it was
started we've done more than seven
months of in eight years and so were
they good there but what happens is now
they flee and they flee that Africa and
they flee denies year and countries
around them and that's how these you
know people get attacked and they got
attacked by fifty real fighters but
these were people in many cases that
were in the Middle East then now go to
Africa to try and you know cause
problems there and ultimately they want
to come back here because this is where
they really
so it's a rough business I don't think
I'd want to be a terrorist who's there
but but that as you know people don't
say that the reason they're there is
because we force them and it's does not
but it's pretty intense and you see that
happening so that's that
I think Hillary's gonna kill Russia so
the real news here is not about Trump
joking about dead servicemembers people
are in the room er laughing Trump does
appear to like with most things not
understand sort of the seriousness of
what's going on but it's it's just not
accurate to say Trump was laughing about
the deaths or even laughing about the
ambush he was laughing about the idea
that it's really bad to be a terrorist
now because he's going after people so
hard
the real revelations from this clip are
number one even in the middle of all
this stuff related to knee chair Trump
still can't say knee chair that that's
notable because at that point he must
have heard it I don't know hundreds of
times from people that are around him
number two that he has no idea what he's
talking about I mean this is a word
salad reminiscent of Sarah Palin who
would experience these completely futile
attempts to use language to communicate
anything of meaning Trump seemingly
falling into sort of that's that same
thing and number three even in private
Donald Trump was still transitioning
from talking about this ambush in
Nazaire to talking about Hillary
colluding with Russia that's the news
here it's not clear that Trump has any
clue what the hell he's talking about
and as far as Trump telling jokes and
his sense of humor the guy has a real
you know what one of the indications
that someone you may have sort of some
serious either personality issues or
mental illness or emotional issues is
that their sense of humor seems very off
in different ways and this is not to
stigmatize any condition or to cast
aspersions it's just sometimes you
notice that somebody has something about
them that is not functioning completely
correctly based on their sense of humor
and what they seem to laugh at or not
laugh at Trump sense of humor has
something fundamentally wrong with it
you might remember he was roasted on
comedy son
some time ago and he seemed completely
unable to sort of get what was going on
and understand humor you might remember
years ago when President Obama was still
president that Donald Trump was in the
audience during the White House
Correspondents Dinner and Obama told
some quite frankly pretty funny jokes
about Donald Trump and Trump simply did
not laugh and it wasn't cleared that he
wasn't laughing because he was upset
that he was that with the butt of jokes
it doesn't seem that he understands
satire or humor but for whatever reason
in this case even though Trump's not
laughing at dead soldiers he found that
the sort of circumstance where he would
joke in general and and the the
disgusting thing is really his general
handling of that ambush in the air we
learned that while on the phone with one
of the wives widows of one of the four
deceased service members Trump seemed to
forget the name of the service member in
question and every element of Trump's
involvement with that raid was
despicable the raid itself its planning
the hugely questionable nature of the
raid to begin with Trump's reactions to
the death totally the deaths plural
totally deplorable but this is not the
the the right headline I believe and I
think that there is a lot of interesting
stuff in this recording from Omarosa by
the way what other recordings does she
have that's really a growing interesting
question but Trump is not laughing at
dead servicemembers as was framed by
some but still a very interesting clip
make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show if you aren't you are missing
behind-the-scenes pictures pictures from
what goes on in the studio from my
recent trip and also make sure you're
following me on instagram at david
pakman quick break Andrew Seidel from
the Freedom From Religion Foundation
joins me next I've said before that when
you start arguing against your own
impeachment with anything short of I
haven't
any impeachable offense you're already
on the defensive and you're sort of
losing and Donald Trump did this a
couple of weeks ago during a Fox News
interview I played that for you I think
it was about ten days ago where Donald
Trump said when he was asked about
impeachment if I were to be impeached
the stock market would crash and
everyone would be very poor he's now
going further he had another one of
these wacky rallies in Montana a few
days ago where he could barely put
together a coherent sentence he was
unable to say the word anonymous
multiple times very very strange but
during that rally he again started
arguing against his own impeachment not
by saying I simply haven't committed any
impeachable offense but by saying that
if he were to be impeached the United
States would be turned into a
third-world country he also threatened
to blame his own supporters if the
impeachment happens making the case that
if Republicans win in the fall he won't
be impeached let's take a look at the
first clip here I'll be the only
president in history they'll say what a
job he's done by the way where I beat
him he'll say we want to impeach him
then you'll beat him it's so ridiculous
but worry about that if it ever happens
but if it does happen it's your fault
because you didn't go out to vote you
didn't go out there you didn't go out to
vote okay and then there's this part
where he gets to the third-world country
stuff so we're in there we've got the
best employment numbers in our history
we've got the best economy in our
history you look at the numbers in every
category it's great we're doing a great
job we're putting on phenomenal judges
and you take that and you do then what
you're going to have is you have a
country that's going to turn in to a
third world country yeah it wouldn't be
just House and Senate Democrats who want
Trump impeached if that happened because
49% of Americans according to an ABC
news/washington post poll from about ten
days ago said they believe impeachment
proceedings should begin nearly half the
country thinks that there should be
impeachment proceedings against the
president that
it's not merely partisanship because
when you've got 49% agreement on
anything it's not just one party by mere
math but I want to focus on a slightly
different element of this there have
been a lot of analyses done about this I
want to talk about Trump's use of the
term third-world country we often call
them developing nations but okay Donald
Trump is saying third world country the
United States already shares a lot of
characteristics with developing nations
when you look at our health care system
it quite frankly doesn't have that much
in common with other developed nations
who provide basic health care as a right
to everybody regardless of their ability
to pay and along the health lines when
you look at infant mortality in the
United States it's quite high among
developed nations and is more
reminiscent of a developing nation but I
want to go and take it even another step
further when you look at the United
States on paper you can't deny that at
least on average the u.s. is a developed
nation in many categories okay but the
average as I've talked to you before and
how to lie with statistics the average
depending on whether it's mean median
mode and and and how what data you're
interpreting it is very misleading and
what we have in the United States when
we look at standard of living when we
look at economics when we look at access
to health care the country as a whole is
very propped up by cities and by blue
states which often have a stronger
infrastructure as a result of having in
many cases higher taxes when you look at
conditions like access to health care
access to education infrastructure
including Internet access when you look
at rural red states in the United States
it's worse than just about every
developed nation and it's often not even
as good as many developing nations does
Donald Trump know that I have no idea I
would guess that he doesn't and this is
exactly what I'm increasingly referring
to as weaponized cognitive dissonance
and weaponized ignorant
and it's weaponized because it's
catalyzing the deplorable x' call them
whatever you want I don't think it's a
hugely offensive term but you know who
I'm talking about the trumpets whatever
they are being catalyzed by lies
ignorant and cognitive dissonance from
Trump to get behind horrible ideas that
neither they nor their fearless orange
leader understand but remember to go
back to the beginning Trump is now
making arguments regularly against his
own impeachment and they are arguments
other than I've done nothing worthy of
impeachment today's episode of the David
Pakman show is made possible in part by
zip recruiter there are job sites that
send you tons of the wrong resumes to
sort through or make you wait for the
right candidates to apply to your job
that is not smart what is smart is going
to zip recruiter dot-com slash Pakman to
hire the right person
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them for
you it's powerful matching technology
scans identifies and looks at resumes to
figure out who has the right skills who
is the right education who has the right
experience for your job and it will
proactively invite them to apply so that
you get qualified candidates quickly no
more sorting through the wrong resumes
no more waiting for the right candidates
to apply and that's why zip recruiter is
rated number one by employers in the
United States this rating comes from
hiring site SunTrust pilot with over a
thousand reviews and right now my
viewers and listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash Pakman
that's zip recruiter comm /p a que ma n
one more time zip recruiter dot-com
slash Pakman it's the smartest way to
hire I really struggled earlier with how
to sort of present this story to you so
that it would transmit the true
absurdity that it
presents so maybe the best place to
start is with some basics like for
example the federal deficit has been
skyrocketing under Donald Trump the
federal deficit is up nearly a third 32%
in the first 11 months of fiscal 2018
over fiscal 2017 of about two hundred
and twenty two billion dollars this is
according to the nonpartisan
Congressional Budget Office why is the
deficit up well the Republican tax law
is part of the problem and increases in
spending are part of the problem if you
reduce tax revenues and you increase
spending your deficit is going to go up
nothing mathematically complicated about
that what is expected to happen next
year and the year after more of the same
the same Congressional Budget Office
estimates that we are going to have more
deficit growth in 2019 fiscal year 2019
and then even more beyond that in fiscal
year 2020 so first of all let me make
very clear this is not a conversation
about whether deficits matter and how
much they matter we've talked a lot in
the last year and a half to two years
about modern monetary theory and the
growing reality that a dollar of deficit
is not always the same for the economy
the deficit spending on stuff that
stimulates the economy is good right
it's not or at least it's not
necessarily bad but on the other hand
growing the deficit to give rich people
tax cuts that they will put mostly in
bank accounts is not good for the
economy but that's not what I want to
talk about today right we've got that
part down we've talked about that many
times Donald Trump ran on reducing the
deficit and on paying down the national
debt the exact opposite is what's
actually happening but I think even more
importantly than that we got these new
deficit numbers the day after we found
out that when former Trump economic
advisor Gary cone went to trump and said
mr. Trump whatever he calls a mr.
president who cares what whatever name
he had for him he said Donald Donny boy
the federal funds rate is going to go up
Donald Trump had the bright idea
of starting to print more money in order
to then make money by holding US
currency which he would just print now
you can debate whether that's a good
idea but Trump and Republicans have run
for decades on economic theory that
supposedly claims that you can't do that
that that is inflationary and that it is
an absolute economic disaster to do that
what we have learned from this
experiment are a few different things
number one Trump and Republicans don't
care about the deficit I've been saying
this for a while it's a political
football the deficit matters when Barack
Obama is in office I'd say when Bill
Clinton's in office although he had a
surplus at the end of his presidency but
when george w bush is in office or
donald trump is in office who could
deficit who cares about the deficit
we're cutting taxes for the rich and for
big corporations deficit I don't even
know what you're talking about that's
what we learned number one even though
we already probably knew that number two
and this is not a new theme Donald Trump
has no idea how money works I'm not
talking about economics he obviously has
no idea how economics works he doesn't
seem to understand how money works and
then thirdly and this is the really sort
of damaging important stuff
Republicans will then use the fact that
these deficits exist because they gave
tax cuts to the rich to support more bad
policy by saying listen we've got
deficits we've got to cut Medicare and
we've got to cut Social Security
benefits even though they caused the
problem I jokingly what was that phrase
I've been using about the Trump
administration solutions that don't work
two problems that don't exist
this is solutions that don't work two
problems you caused and that's when it
starts to ruin people's lives in a real
way and again I know people are going to
write to me because every time I talk
about debt and deficit people write in
with two different basically two
different themes number one people write
in clearly misunderstanding the
difference between debt and deficit I'm
not going to review that today we've
already talked about that before the
other one is I
emails from people saying David you
don't still think the deficit matters to
you and the answer is well the deficit
does matter but what modern monetary
theory is increasingly illuminating is
that a dollar of deficit is not always
created equal and what matters is why
did we get into that deficit dollar in
the first place was it to give a rich
person another dollar to stash away in
their bank accounts in a totally non
economically stimulative way or did that
dollar go to give someone health care
who now by virtue of being healthier is
going to work more and make more money
and the government gets more money
because they're earning income taxes or
collecting income taxes and that person
now has more money to go out and spend
it at local businesses that's what
matters
okay so if you're gonna write in and say
David the deficit doesn't matter at all
I've not seen evidence to suggest it
doesn't matter at all but what I am
increasingly convinced of is that what
matters is how did we get into that
deficit over the long term if you're not
following the david pakman show on
instagram you're missing a lot of really
great stuff including david pakman show
videos on IG TV we are on instagram at
david pakman show please follow us there
and make sure you're also following me
if you want to see behind the scenes
pictures from my trip and everything
that I've been doing over the last
couple of weeks follow me on instagram
at david pakman we will take a quick
break part two of my interview with
Andrew Seidel from the Freedom From
Religion Foundation next then more
stories and a lot of really great stuff
coming up today